America are you ready for Joe Biden's
big comeback well you better be because
Democrats in the media claim Biden is
about to turn his failed presidency
around and follow in the footsteps of
Ronald Reagan instead of Jimmy Carter so
how's Joe going to do it well Democrats
are rushing to jam through a 433 billion
dollar climate and social spending bill
after getting the green light from
Senator Joe manchin Mansions promising
the bill will not raise taxes or make
record inflation even worse
last year you said the American Rescue
plan the coveted relief bill would not
cause inflation so why should Americans
believe you now when you say that this
new bill will not exacerbate inflation
I made sure I don't make that mistake
again that's the bottom line it does not
raise taxes and I've said this before I
said all we did was close loopholes this
is a red white and blue Bill honest to
God that's all it is it's an American
bill
but a new study says the bill will raise
taxes on millions of Americans earning
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year breaking a key campaign promise
from the big guy
but the White House says it is a big lie
well that is incorrect so the joint
committee on taxation which you guys
heralded
and body when you were selling that
infrastructure package is not to be
trusted here I said it is not correct
because I will give you why it's not
correct because it is incomplete
Republicans are slamming the massive
spending plan even saying Mansion has
been flat out tricked by the left
in this time of a recession this time of
High Cost of Living is not the time to
Tinker with the tax code in a way that I
cannot see anything but bad news coming
from it all of this spending is
unnecessary it's going to exacerbate
inflation I like Joe very much but I
think he got taken to the cleaners I
believe inflation gets worse the experts
who are looking at it believe experts
believe that the inflation will get
worse and this is false advertising by
the Democrats businesses don't say they
spend and you grow the economy like I
said now they're going to be saving
money and and it's not and it's really
going to destroy our economy
Can You Feel the excitement in the air
Joe Biden turning this presidency around
did you sense it Greg it's so bad that
you see our nation's politicians living
in their cars you see he was doing an
interview that was his home I love how
the media are just dying to say
something positive about Joe oh my
goodness he had a good week he passed
something other than gas seriously I
almost expect him to say like oh look he
made a boom boom and he flushed you know
he's it's so pathetic and it's the
opposite of trump where they would do
anything possible not to say something
nice even when he passes like a historic
foreign policy Bill the problem with all
this spending is it's basically now
printing right I mean we're just we're
just basically churning out dollars and
it makes sense because we have an
Incredible Shrinking president with an
Incredible Shrinking dollar and it's a
race to see who becomes molecular I keep
thinking you know you could probably at
this point fold up Joe and put him in
tyrus's wallet the um the the other
thing though that we didn't mention I
thought that we were was talking about
what what the Democrats are doing about
the their the races the fact that
instead of actually trying to improve
their party they're meddling with the
the Republicans yeah
yeah did you guys switch stuff on me
yeah no I'm trying to keep you on your
toes Greg well it makes me taller
anything to help Katie Mansion we here
got this big pipeline payoff in West
Virginia so he's satisfied there yeah
but our Democrats gonna going to be
really
excited by by the spending on the
climate and the weather so much so that
they're going to stop the so-called Red
Wave from happening talking about the
big comeback yes the big comeback uh so
Joe Biden on the campaign Trail is
nowhere to be seen and not because he
has covered and he's isolating in the
White House Democrats on the campaign
Trail don't want him anywhere near their
campaigns he is the most unpopular
president since World War II he's about
to lose the house and he also um has
overseen the highest inflation increase
since the 1970s now inflation is a tax
so when Joe manchin tries to justify
this new spending bill by saying it
doesn't raise taxes even though it does
Joe Biden has implemented a 9.1 percent
tax on Americans through inflation with
all the legislation the first time
around this is the inflation reduction
act which is a total lie a total lie and
yes Joe manchin is getting a pipeline
but something the by Administration
should be green lighting regardless of
getting a spending package in return and
they're not doing that and the money
that's in this package for the green
lobby which has been harassing Joe
manchin at his his his house which is a
houseboat in Washington DC
um they're getting a bunch of money to
subsidize Chinese solar panels to bring
into the United States so again uh West
Virginia is a the fifth most fifth
poorest state in the country this is an
inflationary bill it's going to make Joe
manchin's constituents uh in you know
put them in a much more difficult
position financially and inflation will
get worse as a result so yes they get
the pipeline but they're also going to
pay a lot more for everything that they
need on a daily basis so Jessica let's
just say a year from now
some democrat gets up there and they say
well we spent all this money
and then they're going to say on what
and they we spent it on Green
and then can they point to anything they
say well we did this there's a solar
panel there's a solar panel there's a
windmill are they going to ever point to
anything like they still haven't built
any of these charging stations a year
later I haven't seen one new charging
station
where are you looking everywhere they
were supposed to be everywhere I haven't
seen one okay well Jesse Waters test the
Democrats have failed other parts of the
country maybe they're doing a little bit
better on the charging stations and
there are real tangible benefits for
everyday Americans in this bill when you
in a year where they're gonna look back
and say they're gonna say oh I had my
health care coverage increase for
another year with the Obamacare
subsidies they might say that my
prescription drugs cost less because
guess what we can negotiate our own
prices that's a pretty big deal they
just paid off the insurance companies
100 billion dollars no the insurance
companies didn't want that that's the
subsidy what I'm sorry I don't want to
interrupt you I've been told I've been
interrupting too much you continue
please finally
about this this raising the taxes point
so the joint committee on taxation was
the one organization that said that
Moody's and the committee for
responsible budget did not say that they
said actually it would be lowering
inflation there's something that goes on
with the joint committee on taxation in
terms of how they model what happens
when you raise the corporate tax rate so
they changed this model in 2013
basically to shift it from that you're
looking at me like you're bored but it's
relevant ask me a joint committee on
taxation but that's that's the report
that's exciting
so they used to say that shareholders
would just absorb all of the burn from
that when you raise the corporate tax
rate they changed that in 2013 to say
that it would seep past the shareholders
and it would affect everybody else but
that's just a modeling assumption this
actually is not a tax bill Joe manchin
is telling the truth Katie I see you
shaking your head there but the only
thing that changes is this 15 corporate
tax rate on firms that are earning over
a billion dollars and I I find it the
height of hypocrisy that eight days ago
or whatever it was if you talked about
Joe manchin every Republican would say
he's saving America he's the only sane
person and today he's an idiot who got
duped by Alexander you don't live in the
past he didn't get duped he got bribed
by a pipeline the guy in the car he said
he got duped yes that's the definition
of a recession when Republican senator
is living out of his car Kennedy your
response he's pushed back on his own
party so often the Democrats hate Joe
manchin and every politician I don't
care I don't care what party they are I
don't care which state they're from they
want to be liked and Joe manchin has
said so much had said no to so many
things that at some point he had to say
yes he had to say yes to something and I
think what he's betting on is he wants
to look like the hero he wants to look
like the guy who's playing ball because
he knows Kirsten Cinema is going to be
Senator no no no because she has not
made her opinion clear at this point and
I think she will be a hero to arizonans
if she pushes back on this this could be
her Taiwan and Katie is absolutely right
inflation is a tax when you have a wage
increase of three percent but you're
paying nine percent that still is six
percent Gap that most Americans can't
afford right now uh they're closing
loopholes which is increasing taxes on
people who are single entity
corporations these loan through
corporations where they're gonna Crush
Americans who are their own hedge fund
manager no no no that that is the
carried interest loophole that's
completely different I'm talking about a
single entity pass-through corporations
which are going to get hosed through
this and no one is talking about that
but millions and millions of American
businesses operate this way and it's the
only way they can survive by having a
list of deductions that they write off
so they can keep their businesses
running and their families fed all right
Senator Cinema the ball is in your court
your Taiwan girl I feel very fbn right
now it went right over my head hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else